welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation
titled tumor markers and prostate cancer
screening
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
victor mate
dr matey is a member of the haifu clinic
medical team and currently works at the
european institute of technology
in milan italy as the head of urology
training activity
and the institute's premier robotic
surgeon
dr mate has personally performed over
four thousand procedures
including over two thousand endoscopic
procedures and over one thousand robotic
procedures
utilizing the groundbreaking da vinci
robotic system
he has been an adjunct professor at the
urological residency school
at the university of milan's faculty of
medicine
for over 11 years for a complete
biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions
following this presentation please join
me in welcoming
dr victor mate i will now turn the
presentation
over to him okay
good morning everybody i want to
start my presentation with these two
graphics
let all you know showing the effect of
psa introduction into the clinical
practice on prostate cancer
incidence and mortality and the rate of
men presenting with metastatic disease
the reason is that based on this data
the expectation of significant positive
results from a psa based screening
were huge the aim of any screening
program
and thus of prostate cancer too is the
early detection of cases
able to undergo radical treatment and
having as final result
the reduction of overall and
cancer-specific mortality
as far as prostate cancer screening is
concerned
the high rate of false negative biopsies
and the high rate of clinical
non-significant disease
might decisively interfere and prevent
to reach the expected mortality
reduction
as a final result of the screening
program
various reviews and meta-analyses of the
european and the u.s screening trials
showed that the benefit is really small
and regards only the cancer-specific
mortality
so to be weighted against the inherent
risk of over-diagnosis
and over-treatment as the psa
is not a tumor marker but an organ
marker
the early detection of potential in
later little cases
is counteract by a low specificity
of psa while the risk of overtreat
clinically non-significant disease
is enhanced by the underuse of active
surveillance
based on the evidence of the risk of
over diagnosis and over treatment
and of the treatment important side
effects the u.s preventive service task
force
issued in 2012 a great d
recommendation against psa based
screening highlighting the limitations
in the historical implementation of
screening
the effects of this recommendation were
a sharp decline of psa tests
of biopsies and the increase of patients
presenting with metastatic disease
with the risk of reversal to the figures
of the pre-psa
era there was an increase of second
testing before biopsy two
and an incentive to find more specific
biomarkers
moreover it was an increasing
understanding of the evidence
that early detection has at least
partially driven
the observed prostate cancer mortality
reduction over time
as a result in 2017 the u.s preventive
services task force upgraded the psa
screening to a great sea recommendation
meaning a balanced approach to prostate
cancer early detection
emphasizing a shared decision
that decision making and appropriate
risk-based management
for men at risk of prostate cancer
concerning both screening
and biopsy performance
if the particular cancer is forget the
high efficiency of all therapeutic means
under asd underestimates
the role of early detection and overall
cancer
survivors cancer-specific survival
correlate strong overall and chances to
specific survival correlates strongly
with the choice of the appropriate
treatment
rather than with an early diagnosis
for the prostate cancer instead the
optimization of diagnosis
impacts more this seasonably on the
cancer-specific survival rather than the
choice
of an appropriate treatment
biomarkers both molecular and
majestic may turn determinant in
improving the
efficiency of the diagnostic process
but also as risk stratification and dust
in the therapeutic strategy
the use of biomarkers in screening and
the optimization
of the diagnostic strategy is need to
avoid
unnecessary biopsies and to improve the
prostate biopsy performance in favor of
clinical significant diseases
as far as the therapeutic aspect is
concerned
the role of biomarkers might be relevant
in risk adjustment
treatment choice moreover noble
biomarkers have been implemented
to standardize and appropriate use of
active disturbance
the diagnosis algorithm helped us to
better design and develop biomarkers in
order to improve the screening process
especially in some critical points
the share of the cheesy making between
the primary care provider neurologist
and patient is the cornerstone of the
actual approach
the risk assessment and stratification
aim to improve the efficiency
of this tailored screening process
risk factors impact both on the
population
to be screened and on the age when they
start
of screening
surprisingly looking for the review
articles
dealing with this item during the last
five years
the conclusions are almost the same
despite relentless efforts
the paper this paper written at the end
of the 2015
ones about the need to increase the
accuracy of piecing screening
to find more rapid and specific
detection markers
suggesting as a possible solution the
integration with
genetic tests after five years
this other review with the same item
concludes identically suggesting as
imperative
to overpass the deadlock the biomarker
combination
as a consequence the research must go on
in fact looking into the body of these
papers some interesting data may be
noted
as previously showed due to its low
specificity
for clinical significant prostate cancer
psa showed itself in surface
insufficient
as the screening mark marker
at least if used alone prostate health
index
for calicrine scroll
combining psa is a forms improve the
area under the curve in the diagnosis
i think gene and clinical data are also
considered
the so-called novel set of markers such
as the
insulin like growth factors
interleukin-6 an interleaving system
solver receptor even if thought
promising
they did not found practical application
and the last review does not even
mention
them an interesting chapter
is the urine markers the pca3
received the fda approval to be used in
patients suspicious for prostate cancer
having a first negative biopsy
the genomic rearrangement mostly gene
fusion involving tmprss2
and erg transcription factor
occurs in up to 50 percent of prostate
cancer patients
having a specificity of 93 percent
and a positive productive value of
94 percent
it combines pca 3 with tmpr ss2
erg to estimate the risk of prostate
cancer
and thus to help the children making for
prostate biopsy the select
md test is designed to measure
rna levels of two genes dlx1
and hero xc6
exosomes are small extracellular
vesicles
involved in intracellular communication
recent data has shown that first to
mention
mprss2 erg can be detected in
extracellular vesicles from urine
samples
x-406 and integrated with clinical data
extra dx tests
prostates are secretary granules
produced and delivered by prostate cells
allowing the spermatozoa survival in the
female genital tract
and finally the recommendation
their ability
their ability
of immunosuppression invasive support
angiogenetic capacity are potentially
cancer promoting properties
and even if
the to assist fertilizing sperm cells
after 50 years of age seemed to turn
against the hostile cell promoting its
malignant transformation
as a result they potentially may become
prostate cancer detection biomarkers
what about
exosomes they are also vesicles
smaller than prostazones containing
micro rna messenger rna
and even viral peptides content
protected by a double
membrane the most
the most important content are the micro
rna
small non-coding single-stranded rna
involved in regulation of mrna
their resistance to rnas
confirms them a sufficient stability
in most body fluids
here you can see microrna involved in
malignant transformation of prostate
cells
while in this second table
a micro rna involved in preventing it
thus micrornas
seems useful tools not so much for
diagnosis
than as predictors of clinical outcome
of protein
prostate cancer patients
an interesting chapter regards the
tissue markers
the confirmed md test performed on the
tissue obtained from a negative biopsy
and
analyzes the methylation of three
biomarkers
and may turn fundamental in indicating
to repeat the biopsy
here the majestic biomarkers
according to the two trials performed
performing the multi-parametric mri
before the biopsy
it reduces the over detection of
clinical
non-significant disease by 37 percent
missing only 4 percent and reducing
the biopsy by 32 percent
as this pathway may be cost effective
only
in the long term actually it requires
changes in healthcare system
in order to accommodate appropriate mri
capacity
and to guarantee the training needs for
radiologists and neurologists
as a result the use of molecular
biomarkers
might be might be
useful in selecting patients and thus
limiting the need of performing mri
or in pirate's three already documented
legends selecting patients worked on the
row biopsy
this suggested even if crowded table
resumes the role and the utility of
previously discussed biomarkers and they
are used in clinical practice
even if all dimension markers outperform
the psa
they think they find limitations in a
rooting use
as a consequence the development of gene
panels
combined with the imaging and clinical
data
may be the solution to implement their
use
the most interesting screening test
seems to be
this one based on the circulating tumor
cells
using immunocytochemistry techniques
here you can see the study design in
this non-randomized study
the positive predictive value and the
negative
predictive value resulted close to 100
clearly superior to the psa and even to
the association psa mri
the combined circulating tumor cell
detection
and immunocytochemistry seems a very
promising promising
screening test waiting to be tested on a
population level
and i conclude emphasizing that nowadays
psa screening has to be
individualized risk adjusted
and associated with the mri in order to
avoid
unnecessary biopsies the circulating
tumor cell individification
using immunocytochemistry
techniques seems the more more the most
promising screening test but it needs
further evaluation on population level
finally the integration with genomic
tests such as micro rna
may turn out imperative for both
detection and prediction
of clinical outcome
thank you very much and if there are
some questions i would be happy to
answer them
thank you dr mattei for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move on to the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
our first question is why do you think
pfa based screening is not working
so mainly the problems are
allowed specificity for cancer specific
cancer significant significant cancer
patients so with the psa
they were discovered many patients
having clinical and non-significant
disease
and that's why at the end of the
screening process
the benefit of reducing the mortality
was not evident because the majority of
patients found with this disease were
clinical
non-significant significance so they
were
they were fit only for active
surveillance and not for treatment
okay and our second question
is what do you think about circulating
tumor cell detection so the
circulating tumor cell detection is a
very promising
method it was of course
used before in discovering if
the disease has or
has not metastases
secondary they it was a very interesting
study about the tumultuous
circulating cells um
showing that there were also
stem cells and natural cells
the use of these cell
these circulating cells two more tumor
cells
is very promising because the technique
used to find the tumor cells
is the immunocyto
chemistry method that there are used
also
for for example in
to see tumor cells in urine
and the technique is very very
easy and very uh
very very good very very reliable
and that's why i think this is one of
the
best techniques to make diagnosis in
this study
there were also patients with second
tumor
or with three tumors
not only prostate cancer but also
kidney cancer or lymphomas so this
method seems
really very promising
well thank you again dr victor mate and
thank you to the audience for those
outstanding questions
we hope you found today's presentation
to be informative and insightful
this presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing
don't miss out on the other valuable
presentations on our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
until next time
goodbye